you realize that your Instagram account
is very strong I was talking about it
this morning when we were talking about
what's going on with that are you
putting an inordinate amount of time
into Instagram none it's just all this
material it's honestly as easy as I see
something and then I just I usually go
for walks so if I see something I will
just hold the button and film it and go
that's funny and then just put it out
there and not think too much of it at
all because it's very throwaway and even
on the show the new TV show the new TV
show they were like we should work that
in which does sound like a good idea
it's more interesting and newer and
weirder and a little different so we're
using them as bumpers right now and
trying to throw in and out with them see
that's the problem with a new TV show
your your mind is incredibly quick it
standup
you've got great Instagram account going
now you get on TV and you're gonna start
the show next Monday it's more pressure
in all this do you tighten up or do you
think that this will be finally the show
that shows david spade's yeah that's a
good question um how are we protecting
you in this who's figuring this whole
show out were you burning to do a show I
think I like a place where I can do my
own sense of humor